joining us now for more on this is our
chief Washington correspondent Major
Garrett major I felt like someone said
Hey Siri play Donald Trump's Greatest
Hits and off he went what stood out to
you and what does it tell us about 2024
so let's think about this metaphorically
as one hour at a political Golden Corral
a buffet okay
and what happens at a buffet When Donald
Trump is the host well because he says
so many things that are factually
inaccurate all the food is mislabeled
but that doesn't mean customers don't
get what they want for Trump customers
they loved the jokes they loved the
Biden bashing they love the January 6th
revisionism and they love the sense that
he was in the media's Lions Danity
pushback so Trump supporters got what
they wanted Democrats also at this
metaphorical political Golden Corral got
what they wanted they saw Trump say that
he was proud to have paved the way to
ending National protections legally for
abortion saying that the answer to
inflation is to drill drill drill for
climate change motivated voters that's a
red line they also heard him say that
default is a real option and not such a
bad thing Democrats got a lot out of
this Golden Corral experience as well so
too probably did Jack Smith the special
counsel here in Washington because he
heard a lot about Trump's understand
motivations and frame of mind regarding
documents he took to Mar-A-Lago and
everything leading up to his mentality
about January 6th so whether Trump
intended to or not three different
customers at this political Golden
Corral metaphorically came got what they
wanted and probably left more satisfied
than they thought they would be well
major I guess journalists in this
metaphor of yours are kind of like food
inspectors they're there to make sure
thing everything is sanitary and up to
code what lessons were there last night
for how to cover this unusual candidate
in the months ahead the facts are real
and Donald Trump will give what he
regards and what if his supporters
regard as contextual truths what do I
mean by that Trump lied and lied again
about the 2020 election but he also said
things that for his supporters have gone
beyond the facts of whether or not the
2020 election was stolen of course it
wasn't but he talks about Hunter Biden's
laptop he talks about the FBI and
Twitter files all those things
contextually ring so much more true to
his supporters they don't care about
those other things so in that sense we
established the facts we remind the
voters of that and Trump's politics will
be Trump's politics and the country will
make its ultimate decision if he's the
nominee
all right major I will say Golden Corral
never mislabels its food it's terrific I
always find it on the road when I'm out
there we appreciate the metaphor though
it's a good one